So now, with the cloud,
you can play across your devices.
And all your data is saved
automatically for you, which is great.
But what about if you lose the game?
Maybe a game is like Flappy Bird and
you lose every few seconds, or
is that just me?
Do you stop playing?
Of course not.
You keep going for a while and
try to beat your record.
And this is because it's so
easy to keep playing.
Flappy Bird let's you crash and
burn, then start over just
by tapping the screen.
This is a lot easier than classic
arcade games where when you lose,
you have to type in your
name to record a game score.
And then insert more quarters
if you want to play again.
So to keep your players interested,
it's important to include
an easy restart in your game.